vous allez pas conduire un petit peu
mais c'est les reines qui font tout le
boulot
c'est ma quatrième année en père Noël et
toi alors c'est moi qui suis responsable
de ce merdier
[Musique]
on a décidé que tu pourrais avoir un
cadeau en avance
qu'est-ce que c'est la ligne directe du
Père Noël en personne
le Père Noël c'est parti les lutins
bienvenue dans le pire Noël de votre vie
on y va
tu as 300 millions de dollars dans ton
coffre-fort
voilà c'est ça que je veux pour Noël
[Musique]
je veux pas dormir d'accord je vais mes
clipser par cette cheminée
[Musique]
dis-moi qui c'est parce que c'est pas un
père Noël de centre commercial
Père Noël tu es là
[Musique]
papa a dit que tu étais très occupé
cette nuit
je m'appelle croodilight tu vas nous
aider Père Noël
tu es sur la liste des enfants sages
le Père Noël débarque en ville
[Musique]
c'est l'heure d'envoyer les marrons
et si c'était le vrai non le Père Noël
n'existe pas
c'est ça le type ça tous sur la liste
des gens passent
tu leur donnes quoi un morceau de
charbon
je crois en toi Père Noël
lequel d'entre vous a fait ça c'est toi
c'est pas du tout professionnel